so ball nine  for 17 tonight two for five from beyond  the yard  over 50 overall 24.7 rebounds so he  really rebounded for rebound  not the rebound but from the first half  he just had an off first half that's one  thing players realize there's 48 minutes  in the game  just because you don't do well the first  half doesn't mean anything and lebron  and he lays it in for the last laker  shot at the game  lebron james two more he's got  37 tonight  and for lebron that's his third highest  scoring game  of the year the melo at the other end  and this one is  over to 105.  [Applause]  yeah the lakers you know they were in  control they  blew big blew a big lead again but they  gathered themselves  did what they needed to do from  defensive standpoint once the  pelicans pushed the hornets  there it is lebron james with 37 points  eight rebounds six resists look it  breaks his streak  of triple doubles right two in a row but  a lightwork 37.  and it's amazing